still getting used to this videoing of
myself here walking down the street i've
got to go downtown for a business
meeting at a business meeting in my
office
and i'm trying to decide
whether i go
to
carmelo's over there
uh or
whether for some italian which i'm not
suffering or i might just go
here to yanaki and have again some sushi
and maybe speak a few words of korean i
think i'll go for yanaki
pasta
um
video toy uh youtube channel it's all uh
how do you say um
uh i'll put it up on my youtube channel
but
uh what is your name
um
thank you
so yeah here we are and i'm enjoying my
korean food and my neighbor says why am
i learning korean
which is a good question
so we will turn it around and this is my
neighbor here and what is your name
susan susan
sylvan sylvan and so you're saying why
am i learning korean good question
i like to learn languages
i speak chinese and japanese
and so it's easier for me to learn
korean i also did it a few years ago and
i have this website for language
learning and i'm also doing a
a 90-day challenge in korean
and and as part of that i'm doing these
little videos that i put up on my
youtube channel
does that answer your questions
did this a
well about seven or eight years ago i
decided to learn korean now i'm supposed
to learn how to swing this around here
so that
yeah so i decided to learn korean
because i speak chinese and japanese
so i spent about six or seven months
an hour a day listening and reading
working with different beginner material
that i could find and then i gave it up
because there was no interesting content
because i've learned other languages
russian czech you know portuguese
whatever and i was able to find
interesting content and to me language
learning involves a lot of listening and
reading to stuff that's interesting
so then i gave it up but i decided that
i would start up again
and do you speak other languages yes
what do you speak
uh english french germans
oh that's pretty good
no asian languages oh wow
it's flattering a witch
it's a native language oh wow how did
you learn that i was interested i
thought
we're supposedly a mod
but
i believe that the
real moral obligation is to know and
understand the first nations i agree
with you you know what on that note i
will let you eat
but i agree and we'll continue our
conversation off video okay
hi there if you're a tall observant
you'll notice that there is a
hangul chart it's a bit of a reflection
on it behind me i'm going to start
working a little harder at my hunger the
second week
today's the last day of my first week
tomorrow i will speak in korean maybe a
monologue maybe i'll go and find someone
to talk to a little bit longer in korean
i'm not really yet in my speaking phase
i'm still trying to get more of the
language in me get better at
understanding what people are saying
i still feel that i my comprehension
hasn't improved that much although i'm
listening over and over again and i'm
reading and i'm listening but i know
from experience with checking with
russian with other languages that it's
just a matter of time before all of a
sudden things start to become clear more
and more of the jigsaw puzzle becomes
clear and then the other bits eventually
emerge out of the fog
a busy day today we had a chinese lumber
customer business visit us here in our
west vancouver office then i had the
meeting downtown
so other than listening in the car a
little bit of reading this morning it
didn't do too much i'm gonna go have my
workout now with my ipad on my stepper
uh i'm gonna watch the canucks lose
another hockey game and then i'll
probably do a little bit more tonight
i'm gonna of course squeeze a nice
dinner in there somewhere i see my wife
is already preparing the dishes and we
got the second half of the wine bottle
that we started last night
so that's kind of to update you and
tomorrow as i say i'll i'll speak a
little more korean
but i'm not yet in that speaking phase
i'm still in the listening getting it in
me face give me another few weeks and
i'll be speaking a lot more